[Applause]
Mr. Mayor, the
service back
I hope for your understanding
if I have to ask you now
at this hour of remembrance
together with me to commemorate
my father's
repository therese city
my brother
who died auschwitz i
my mother who died
in the same camp
in  died in the gas chamber
and my first wife had to
give up her young life in the bergen belsen camp
i beg
you not to expect even a
single word from me is hate
if i hate too
i only knew the victims
but i know them  not the perpetrators
at least judged guilty not personally
and someone not personally but
collectively lehle is
correct
there is no collective guilt
and believe me i'm not just saying that
today
i said that from the first day
i was liberated at my last
concentration camp  was and
i believe
that the men and women in austria  ch
who today are between only 50 years old
to say collectively guilty
is a crime and
is insanity and
don't let it be phrased as yes
it would be a crime if it weren't a
case of insanity
and a dog fall into the
national socialist  ideology of the
seven liability
that should be said to those who believe they can
say that one has to be shameless about something, although one
hasn't done it
oneself, hasn't even refrained from doing it oneself,
but the parents or
grandparents have to take care of their conscience
the women relate  we should be sure to be
victims of former collective persecution
and be the first to advertise
who agree with me
it would be if they are up to it
the youth of today can be
driven into the arms of the old apsis under the neo-Nazis
please let them be freed for the
moment  come back
i'm in the first possible transport
even if only illegally possible
tr  ansport
returned to vienna
crammed into a truck with a few other
viennese
including rosa jochmann
on 15 august 45
since then
i have been called to america 63 times to be from
universities and so on and every time out of
those 63 times i have returned to
austria not because i  the
austrians would have loved so much but
because austria was laid
and love is based we don't always know
each other
[applause]
it won't be the americans you swam out
why didn't you actually
come to us before the war and
my answer was me  I knew to
explain to them that
I had to wait years for an
entry visa to America
and as it was finally so soon it
must be too late
because I just couldn't bring
myself to leave my old parents alone with the war
and
their shooting  under the
National Socialists
but rather that I
pretended to share this fate  moved
and then americans say all well and good
but why didn't
you come to us in america right after the war
why did you return to vienna
many did too little
to you and in your
then i tell the
americans look in vienna that has its  for
example a catholic baroness was
given we noticed bakers promoting
the choir work through the
iphone spencer and a cousin
of mine kept the whole
thing well hidden in her apartment as she
saved her life and the
counterpart another
example there was a socialist
lawyer  in vienna he was
also endangered in la corte
slipped me a liter of life you know
who that was it was bruno pittermann
and then i ask the americans
now they told me why i went to
a city where so many people are
many since  I have nothing to
hold back
I know very well
know very well what they're going to say to each other now
or what you will hold
against us he asks himself let's be honest that
looks like a big exception were
exceptions to the rule and generally
people were opportunists
they should have resisted and
i have to agree with many men below
but please consider such a
resistance  also requires
heroism
and terrorism, in my opinion you
can actually ask a single
person that is you
and those who say you should
rather be locked up before
you make compromises that I should give
the nazis the fourth
right
but actually that’s only allowed
say someone who
has proved for himself that he
preferred to be put in a concentration
camp instead of letting himself and
his convictions and wood become
[applause]
we all have girls, you can
understand the young generation today how should
because they can understand how
people were back then  then they had to fear
for their freedom for their lives
and for the fate of their families for
these years they had to bear
responsibility all that one has to consider
but all the
more the miracles must have had people in the
courage at the risk of their lives to
join the many starts movement
and  even having to pay for it with
my life like my best friend
at the time his name why he was sentenced to
the wehrmacht establishment
to death and his young life
changed under the guillotine
ladies and gentlemen national socialism hated
the races were upset but
when i him  may reveal how
i think about it then my answer
is that there are actually only two people
this is the race of
decent people and the races are always
people and the racial segregation dietrich
is entertained by a slogan
[applause]
just get in and
currencies other
with concentration camps  one here
and there even
on the one  n or others then
I hit it decent terre just
like vice versa some
tempted ones among the prisoners
danger looms yes only all
decent people who are so dear are in the
minority the
efforts were
my minorities i think will remain mine
but the danger lies elsewhere the
danger  lies where there is no risk a
political system that
indecently cares to pan the surface and in other
words ensure that the negative
selection of the nation takes the helm
that's actually what's going on here
[applause]
[music]
not a single nation
and in this aim it was the  assertion
that basically every nation focus is
active
what are the political consequences
that we can all follow the goals in
my opinion there are
only two games of politics or
let me tell you two types of
politicians the highlanders are the
ones who believe the end justifies
the means of
every shooter
terrorist are
included  other politicians very well
remain in their profession
that means like the
filings themselves want to develop the purpose of
this discussion of politicians bright little
is also trusting that he learns from everything
these march days
I hears the re-engaged and
hears the formula and of the day  or
better said this commemoration day and that
can only be that
all the good will
several times stretch out the hand
can be seen everywhere
[applause]
after this deeply touching and
important speech by professor viktor
frankl the big rally comes to an
end